اعلنت لجنه مكافحه الارهاب الروسيه تعرض
جسر القرم لهجوم وصفته بالارهابي وقالت
انه الحق اضرارا بجزء منه وقالت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ان الهجوم نفذه
نظام كييف الارهاب اما وكاله
فنقلت عن لجنه مكافحه الارهاب الروسيه ان
هجوم جسر القرم نفذ باستخدام زورقين
مسيرين من جهتها اعلنت وزاره الصحه في
منطقه الروسيه مقتل شخصين واصابه فتاه فوق
جسر القمه الذي يربط شبه الجزيره بمنطقه
واعلن عمده
تشديد الاجراءات الامنيه في المدينه على
خلفيه الهجوم على جسر القرن
بدورها قالت مصادر في اداره امن الدوله
الاوكرانيه ان الهجوم الليلي على جسر
القرم هو عباره عن عمليه خاصه نفذتها
القوات البحريه وجهاز الامن الاوكرانيين
ووفقا لجهاز الامن الاوكراني فقد تعرض
الجسر لهجوم بطائرات مسيره بسبب صعوبه
الوصول اليه بوسائل اخرى من جانبه رفض
المتحدث باسم اداره الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه
على حادث جسر القمه واضاف يوسف انه بسبب
تدمير قسما من الجسر سيواجه الروس مشاكل
في الخدمات اللوجستيه لانهم يستخدمون شبه
جزيره القرم محورا لوجستيا كبيرا لتحركات
قواتهم نحو العمق الاوكراني
الان من سفيان مراسل الجزيره مازن ابراهيم
ارحب بك مازن يبدو ان هناك اذن مواقف
رسميه بشان هذه الضربه وبان اوكرانيا فعلا
متورطه فيها
في الواقع السفيان اي مقاربه لموضوع قصف
جسر القرم من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه سواء
اعلن هذا الامر بشكل رسمي واضح او من خلال
المصادر العسكريه التي تسرب الى الصحافه
الاوكرانيه تفاصيل معينه ترتبط باستهداف
الجسر لا يمكن تقديم مقاربه دون الحديث عن
ثلاثه ابعاد البعد الاول يرتبط بالبعد
الامني العسكري المباشر البعد الثاني
يرتبط
ببعض التاريخي والسياسي والرمزي لهذه
المنطقه وكيفيه مقاربه الكيف لموضوع شبه
جزيره القرم اما البعد الثالث فيرتبط
بموضوع انتهاء مفاعيل صفقه الحبوب اليوم
واتفاق الحبوب بين روسيا واوكرانيا برعايه
تركيا عمليا على مستوى البعد الاول الامني
العسكري من الواضح من خلال التسريبات
والمصادر الرسميه
الاوكرانيه التي تحدثت الى الصحافه
الاوكرانيه وتحديدا من جهاز امن الدوله هي
اشارت عمليه الاستهداف نفذتها البحريه
وجهاز امن الدوله في اوكرانيا وبالتالي
كان الهدف هو ايرباك عمليه الامداد
اللوجستي من شبه جزيره القرم للقوات
الروسيه التي تتوغل داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هذا الامر تحدث عنه مصدر في
جهاز امن الدوله وايضا تلميحا واشاره
المتحدث باسمها الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه الذي رفض ان يعلق بشكل مباشر
ولكنه ذكر بمقوله قالها قائد الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه بان هذا الجسر هو امر غير
ضروري وجوده وبالتالي استهدافه يفتح الباب
امام ارباك العدو وفق توصيفهم بطبيعه
الحال ضمن هذا البعد العسكري
الامني يمكن القول بانه نتيجه التطورات
الاخيره على مستوى الجبهات المتعدده وتعثر
الى حد ما الهجوم المضاد الذي تقوم به
اوكرانيا واعتمادها تكتيكات مختلفه تقوم
على القصف في العمق الروسي عمق المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا اوكرانيا بالتالي
يمكن الحديث عن ان التكتيكات باتت مختلفه
واستهداف شبه جزيره انما ياتي ضمن هذا
الاستهداف الكبير وهذا التكتيك المتغير
نتيجه كل ما حصل خلال الاسابيع الماضيه من
تعسر للهجوم المضاد اليوم يشاهد قصفا
قصيرا مدى وبعيد مدى نسبيا من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه في محاوله لاحداث ثغرات على
عده جبهات واستهداف شبه جزيره في سياق
متصل بمعنى عمليه ايرباك القوات الروسيه
في العمق الذي تسيطر عليه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه على المستوى البعد الثاني الذي
يتعلق بالبعد الرمزي اوكرانيا تريد ان
تؤكد بانها تسعى وفق ما تقول قيادتها
السياسيه وقيادتها العسكريه الى تحرير
المقاطعات الاربعه التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
والتي ضمتها سواء عام 2014 كما شبه جزيره
الكرم او ضمتها خلال هذه الحرب الاخيره
وتحديدا المقاطعات الاربعه
ماذا عن وجهه النظر الروسيه ينضم الان
الينا من دونيتس كمراسلنا امين درغامي
اهلا امين اذن حدثنا عن موقف الجانب
الروسي واخر التصريحات الرسميه
نعم ليلى لجنه تحقيق الفيدراليه الروسيه
وضعت هذا الهجوم في اطار في اطار هجوم
ارهابي استهدف منشاه مدنيه باستخدام
الزورقين انتحاريين حملت الجانب
الاوكرانيه المسؤوليه عن ذلك وقالت بانه
يجري الان
الكشف عن الذين قاموا بهذا الهجوم وايضا
من اعطى الاوامر بشنه طبعا على المستوى
السياسي هناك تصريحات
متتاليه من قبل مسؤولين كبار في الدوله
اليوم نائب رئيس مجلس الاتحاد فلاديمير
جابر اعتبر بان ما جرى اليوم يزيد من
ضروره فصل اوكرانيا بحسب قوله عن منطقه
البحر الاسود واعاده كل من مقاطعتي
اوبيسا وايضا نيكولايف الى الحضن الروسي
التاريخي بحسب قوله قبل ذلك كانت هناك
تصريحات
الحديثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه التي
اتهمت الجانب الاوكراني بشن ما وصلته
بالهجوم الارهابي وبتنسيق مع المخابرات
البريطانيه
والامريكيه طبعا هناك دعوات للرد على هذا
الهجوم طبعا ليس هو الهجوم الاول كما نعلم
الجسر تعرض في اكتوبر من العمل الماضي
لتفجير ادى الى مقتل اربعه مدنيين ووقوع
ادرار كبيره احتاج اصلاحها واعاده فتح ذلك
الجسر لشهور عده ولربما الان بدا الحديث
عن الاشغال التي او الوقت الذي يستغرقه
اعاده فتح هذا الجسر الحديث عن نحو شهر
لكن بدا ايضا الحديث عن ايجاد طرق بديله
للوصول الى شبه جزيره القمه هنا يبرز او
تبرز اهميه الطريق البديل الذي يمر من
مقاطعه روستوف عبر اقليم دومباس ومقاطعتي
لكن هناك طبعا مخاوف امنيه كبيره من هذا
الطريق باعتبار ان مقاطعه تشهد عمليات
عسكريه الحرب هناك ما زالت مستعره وايضا
تعرض جسر تشانغار كما حدث الشهر الماضي
لقصف صاروخي اوكراني الان هناك سيناريوهات
عديده لما بعد هذا الهجوم الذي طبعا رغم
انه الثاني لكن كانت هناك محاولات كثيره
قالت السلطات الروسيه انها كانت تستهدف
هذا الجسر كما حدث بدايه هذا الشهر بصد
هجمات صاروخيه كما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن ذلك وايضا قبل ذلك
هجمات تعرضت لها مناطق اخرى في شبه
الجزيره القرن كمدينه
الواقعه على البحر الاسود هناك سيناريوهات
عديده لا يمكن طبعا كما قال الزميل مازن
فصل ما جرى اليوم من هذا الهجوم
بانتهاء صفقه الحبوب هناك رسائل متبادله
جانب الروسي تحدث مرارا عن صعوبه تمديد
هذه الاتفاقيه في ظل عدم احترام البند
الذي ينص على تصدير الحبوب وايضا المنتجات
الزراعيه الروسيه الان الكل ينتظر ماذا
بعد هناك انتقادات طبعا داخليه هنا في
روسيا للاجراءات التي اتخذتها السلطات
لحمايه هذا الموقع الاستراتيجي في مضيق
كرش اي جسر القرم وايضا عمل اجهزه
المخابرات الروسيه خلال الفتره الاخيره
خاصه بعد توالي الهجمات على شبه الجزيره
على الهجمات السابقه خاصه وان توقيت هذا
الهجوم ياتي في وقت بدات فيه او بدا فيه
موسم الاصطياف في شبه الجزيره القرن
وبالتالي هناك توجه عدد كبير من المواطنين
الروس للاستجمام في شبه الجزيره شكرا امين
درغامي كنت معنا من دونيتسكو وشكر موصول
لمازن ابراهيم مراسل الجزيره منصف